[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous pour un magazine de la santé
et allô docteur jean marc bonjour
bonjour mind non en fait je suis en
train de me gratter
j'ai le soft vous essayez de le rue
brendan au docteur tout à l'heure c'est
une hydratation qui m'a fait penser à ça
près d'un an après l'annnonce de leur
premier mort officielle du coc u19 le 29
février 2020 les états unis ont franchi
le cap sinistre du demi million de décès
hier un bilan déchirant a déclaré le
président joe biden avant de respecter
une minute de silence en hommage aux
victimes
les mesures que nous avons pris de
distanciation ou de lavage de mains ou
de nettoyage à l'alcool ont probablement
eu un rôle bénéfique sur la disparition
des affections respiratoires et
digestives mais pas du tout son corps
vide et donc ça veut dire que toutes les
mesures que nous avons prises jusqu'à
présent pour contrôler qu'ovide sont
totalement inefficaces
il y a plus d'américains morts en un an
à cause de cette pandémie que pendant la
première guerre mondiale
la seconde guerre mondiale et la guerre
du vietnam combiné en valeur absolue les
etats unis sont le pays le plus touché
au monde par la pandémie
il ya eu des gens qui ont été contaminés
jusqu'à 200 m des personnes affectées et
donc ça peut expliquer pourquoi on n'a
jamais démontré sa pour les autres virus
respiratoires cette distance incroyable
qui peut y avoir entre les cas infectés
et les cas qui vont être infectées
christine boutin connue on pourrait être
une fervente catholique toujours active
sur les réseaux sociaux et hier grosse
gaffe de l'ex ministre qui s'est énervé
en réaction à un message qui critiquait
jésus alors message de l'internaute en
question met vraiment à quoi sert jésus
faut penser à aller se faire voir un
moment donné
ni une ni deux christine boutin lui
répond et vous qu'avez vous fait pour
stopper les désastres jésus nous laisse
libres et c'est un immense gâteau
regarde toi tu as compris que ça pouvait
pas dans ces savoirs et une batterie
parce qu'en fait ces nuls en victoires
recul quoi devant tous les gens qui font
dire mot comique non donc sauf dieu
l'internaute à qui l on voit ça
commentait en fait la rencontre de
première league qui opposait manchester
city à arsenal dimanche dans les rangs
tête du joueur de manchester city
gabriel gay sousse
forcément c'est pas passé inaperçu
no rick a plus de mal à remonter son
sort à dos parce que parce qu'il est
plus lourd pour vous
donc je pense que c'est plus difficile
au moyen âge on a cité les femmes sur
les marchés et d'acheter des artichauts
parce que ça permettrait de garder
l'effet sochaux une quinzaine à manger
des selleries des tonnes et des tonnes
parce que c'était censé donner de la
vigueur
donc vous vous en avez un grand couteau
c'est l'idée du complexe de nos outils
bah voila voila on est dedans
ok on n'épiloguera pas son la taille du
patron de chez l'homme
avec l'âge on sait qu'il ya une petite
fille bronze et donc le pénis peut
perdre un tout petit peu de son
élasticité de ses capacité érectile et
surtout de sa taille qui peut se
rétracter un minimum non non non je vous
laisse imaginer l'intérêt que peuvent
avoir des hommes pour une petite pour
une alimentation s'il fallait un
argument de taille pour que les objets
je ne suis comme on voit poulets
d'élevage
j'aurais nuit je suis enfermé dans ma
cage numéro 7203 si tu viens je serai là
on ne peut plus aller courir à mon âge a
longtemps mélangent les unes avec de la
farine et du sucre puis il fait chauffer
sont les attentions
on a dix jours fait pas bouillir les
menus les foutus comme le sens enfin
quand un son qui bourre et bien c'est
quand elle beauty sens
une tradition de dunkerque c'est quoi ce
truc
en fait dans nord c'est tout un honneur
il aime trop les odeurs qui pue dans non
ok on va avoir les crocs non mais c'est
sûr qu'il faut suivre les croates ma
chérie piti piti dans la vie du coup je
m'amuse à regarder les crottes à
déterminer l'âge probable de la côte est
du passage du rhinocéros je suis très
serein je suis vraiment dans un safari
puis la vie ici n'est pas si mal trois
repas par jour et le chauffage central
ma santé est très bonne grâce aux
piqûres dorment meneur perte par la
sécurité sociale
qu'est ce qu'elle fait on se demande
alain poirier apparemment c'est une
blague
ces caméras cachées c'est pas possible
non non elle est pas cachée du tout la
caméra mais enfin c'est les riches
aucune ici là c'est pas vidéo gag la
regarder à san francisco une immense
bâtisse victorienne qui a tout
simplement changé d'adressé 465 mètres
carrés déplacer comme ça en plein accord
des films c'est assez un peu et c'est
vrai qu'on dirait des cordes alors un
jeu vous savez en jeu qui serait
grandeur grandeur nature vous êtes très
en forme ce matin
allô allô we are looking for house for
sleep tight end to sleep le we can wait
il y aura in you in your house s'il se
trouve que le propriétaire de cette
maison de cette bâtisse et surtout de ce
terrain a été contacté par un promoteur
immobilier pour un nouveau projet avec
beaucoup d'argent à la clé il a donc
accepté de vendre son terrain mais hors
de question pour lui de
détruire cette maison qui à 139,2 pas
traîné donc il a tout simplement changé
d'adressé cette opération ce
déménagement il a coûté 400 milles de la
yole un portrait en avant la musique
débarrassons ça bien proprement le payer
de l'attique millionnaires du fonds